let's go next to oh where do we go how
about uh
oh you know where let's go to i hope i'm
pronouncing this correctly
is it koya from virginia
yes it is how are you uh very good
i would say and you but you sorry sudden
you're doing fine
thank you what's what's going on so i
actually had two questions if that's all
right i'll try my best to keep it brief
but sure um
it'll depend on their duration yeah fair
enough
um i had a question about the filibuster
and pride month and black history month
first i'll go ahead and start with the
filibuster
okay but with the filibuster
even on the left there is both
agreements and disagreements to keep it
of course the right wants it because
then you know all the republicans can
you know continuously block things as
they have for decades now of course
um but just the same on the left the
concern is that if we remove the
filibuster that suddenly republicans
will have a much easier time pushing
legislation
as we should be able to do so i was
wondering on your thoughts about that i
think that the concern
that if you just destroy the filibuster
it then comes back and hurts democrats
more than it helps them today
is a completely realistic and practical
concern
and part of why it's practical and
realistic
is that republicans have shown that they
do not care about how their political
maneuverings are perceived
their side will not punish them for
doing one thing when it's obama's
supreme court nominee
and a different thing when it's trump's
and then saying if if biden gets one
we'll do a different thing again
their side won't hold them accountable
for the dirty tricks and the hypocrisies
and the maneuverings
so because democrats have not shown a
willingness
to sort of get down in the mud in the
same way i'm not saying stoop to their
level when it comes to corruption and
immorality but
simply when it comes to doing what you
have to do to get political victories
i would be very worried that the appeal
of getting rid of the filibuster right
now
to get a couple things passed would
disgustingly backfire in the future
which is why i end up thinking there
should be
a reformed filibuster that requires it
to
actually be a talking filibuster that
will then
as it goes longer and longer start to be
news
and maybe start to have some political
consequences for republicans like really
make them work for it
that's why i end up where i end up
versus just blowing it up altogether and
it's very practical it's i assume
because democrats are so incompetent it
will backfire against them
i see already so uh moving on to my uh
second question in regards to pride
month and black history month
there always seems to be a lot of
corporate interest involved in that and
to me i consider it like it presents a
danger to
me and my other fellow community members
um as well as just to
even you know straight people and this
is more in regards to pride history
month i'll get on to black history month
at the moment but
people in the community know
usually know better than to fall for the
corporate interest that is
put rainbows on everything sell it here
this is how you support the
community yet at the same time
none of the proceeds ever actually go to
any um
uh you know uh commun or not communities
uh any sort of i forgot the word i'm
sorry
basically any kind of causes yes thank
you okay um that can actually help
people in return the likes of you know
suicide hotlines for trans and you know
of course uh
gay individuals uh so on and so forth as
well as just
you know in regards to even trained
surgery because that stuff is expensive
especially in america
um it's just they they only do it for
themselves
and i wonder what your you know thoughts
are on that and even in regards to
advice that you may give to other people
because they mainly
um prey on straight people saying this
is how you can support
other lgbtq members i've talked to yeah
so i have
a bunch of segments on this i've
basically i mean i've likely
likened it almost to like a fraud
because
it is it is just it it it's
it's a business decision is all it is
and many of these businesses
uh have a long history of donating to
anti-gay politicians while at the same
time celebrating pride month so yeah
check out my clips on it i've talked
about it extensively
alrighty thank you all right thanks very
much um i'm gonna move on because i have
so many people waiting i appreciate the
call we will take a quick break
and then we'll be right back with more
in in mere moments so if you're holding
to talk to me don't hang up